yeah okay how's it going my bros I don't
even know what that is that's what I'm
doing everyone I'm gonna run around
hey we're seeing some new [ __ ] videos
started like that nah of course not
followed by that Shepard one help hope
you're still watching actually after
that have you ever seen anyone on
YouTube saw the video like that nah I'm
a well breaking well jan 27 2014 1 in
hastings my wife and I lived in this
nice warm house we had in the woods of
the large forest near on farmland and
farm running this one night I woke up to
the sound of my wife crying it took me a
little time to realize the voices I
heard she was getting ready nightmares I
had that it was from downstairs I heard
her crying I went there to take a look
oh man she's getting raped by with bro
good job for the pro Wow honestly this
is a great custom mod like actually good
voice acting holy [ __ ] I can't turn it's
pretty [ __ ] obnoxious okay there we
go
ah are you gonna rape today she doesn't
like it
oh it's a bra how can you not like it
I mean I've been raped by the bra
several barrels oh man I don't want to
go there this barrel huh
Oh what's going on oh no no no no no no
no Oh Oh No let's get back out of this
oh [ __ ] it's coming I know it the
barrels
my Lexus my wife was dead and the
monster was after me I had no choice but
to run away into the woods man and so I
ran away I was scared
of course you were you're talking like I
read then at that point I knew that my
life from now on changed in a way it had
never been before and the bro rapes our
girl and your life has changed for sure
[Music]
as I no longer heard the beasts voice
behind me I saw the old Harmons castle
ah I've heard stories it's legendary
fairytales about its Asian pump and it's
stiffed by way they treat our welcome
guests
I never come to be on this OPR
oh man right why are we going here then
I don't want to go no talking with all
these customers so far it's really
interesting it's usually [ __ ] but this
is really good I don't know how this is
when the under my radar holy [ __ ] I'm
super excited to play this first intro
head back ever
yes okay doing the same I guess
ok I don't have to get him warm and
comfort in place I apparently have
passed out and didn't remember fee
someone I didn't know that you don't
remember any links of the place my best
I guess you can notice that I was inside
her ass my name is I still didn't quite
understand what was the meaning of that
monster that attacked the earlier on the
same day and then in a time you find
answers ok let's find some answers
hello Guinea what are you doing in here
I don't even know anymore remember sham
out share my room okay okay
remember sham rare books no I don't want
to go there
I'm slow as hell
stupid [ __ ]
if you wake up I find you lying down in
the front yard so I brought you inside I
didn't find any serious damage
you had look some luck our master
Frances Harmon would be happy in ba ba
ba
okay so Jill Symphony friend Harmon I'm
just doing [ __ ] to us it's doing [ __ ]
not happy about [ __ ] no this is in my
face what talking about something else
another expense I actually got a
headache from that [ __ ] head back I
hope that was worth it oh that I
shouldn't have done it to insult what
we're so early in the morning okay
where's the file I seriously though
I just need soup on oh and then get the
heck out of this place Sonny
Landon would be [ __ ] great
I don't trust paintings I don't trust
anything this is where we came from
right
that are so computing room so many rooms
so confusing I don't even know anymore
let's go here
second that third map whatever the cow
seemed like be a prize inside chilly but
I had paying him what what I even do in
that council I don't I don't even know
it I just have a [ __ ] headache
because I'm a an Aleksandr not a bro
definitely not a bro I mean there's been
a lot about their ancient creatures of
the Damned they follow ambition to still
in its insult in progress in life David
and battery is down there
I don't even know anymore let's go down
here gel it senator kiss it's beautiful
face I don't even care Allah Singh
Richard Harmon uh no it's not Richard
okay we need a key
maybe I shouldn't hear I lost video what
the heck is going on in here did someone
rape your wife really that's awesome
good for your bidding let's continue
all right I don't even know what's going
on in here I have just this month of
Adar ok pity I don't it's me
I'm Cathay edition I'm [ __ ] best but
we down everything alright
back that up for me so I can see okay
okay I got you I got you
I'll keep it they need to find the key
and that's fast bad things happen to
good people all this remedy we told
Salish Becky in the storage room in the
quarters area we need to go to the
cellar oh no no do you hear that vidi
that means you're kind of get betrayed
just be a careful okay okay I'm [ __ ]
careful
seller wait watch the seller
it's the final series of though we're so
it man
why is so sexy oh um well no no no I'm
way to pee they don't discount okay
don't worry I know you hates that use
just I'm Justin for me and it will be
all be okay
I'm tired Isha's too far now I know what
I'm doing untrusted untrusted I'm doing
it I trust you see what I did then I
have the other one okay okay I'll do it
I I don't just yeah I get that I did it
so far
good job ID I am very proud of you no
let's continue further we need to find
the key in the storage room stop hitting
me
Elvis seriously Julia it's very dark in
here be careful
okay in here man you're so screwed with
it yes
matter
[Music]
where's [ __ ] Kate so many doors okay
wait okay that's an oh man I knew the
Susan needs to follow for this one a
cutie
I know storage is really all about it's
always bad news but you need to go I
doubt he'll I'm not even gonna comment
on it anymore you suck if some stars fun
just take it [ __ ] anything here okay I
don't see a key I don't understand a
note that it's the key things up but be
careful bad things might happen
use the bottle if you have to
trying to knock you there we go it's
good what's going on what happened no no
no
okay it's good it's not good it's not
gonna run be there
pity they are very proud of you you're
doing super well but you need to
continue without me I don't go spun all
serious love beauty I don't care what
you say go now we have no time
the master is coming follow he's a break
oh wait this is the water part coming
now
okay Oh freakin
I don't trust corridors oh it's so like
no now oh man I'm breakdown Z I don't
even know what's going on okay okay oh
yes finally
oh thank god hello boughs rap battle
okay
the [ __ ] okay
and it's fauna
see what's up here Mike
[Music]
keep going without a fig a parish bass
hey there's so much a book a pump you
see my cousin's you keep you my cousin
I'm so pumped
mom said hi one day I will be like that
I'm Frank him huh okay I don't even care
anymore I'm taking with me okay baby
okay I'm so freakin pom-pom pretty pound
thank play like look at my sexy buddy
look at my sexy body like my was like oh
man your body's so sexy I just pick one
hell of a fish pound burger one day I
don't even know anymore all right
do you see down there pity that's it
click faster cook I'm gonna go down
there now
well thank you I can not you're fat no
no
jump on me jump on me so I can go down
it's not working piggy okay I know I
don't even know it oh wait there we go
okay hey do you have the hammer you know
I think you know what it in snake I'm
okay
I'll go for anything okay wow that was
awesome good job poopy on man I might
imagine oh it's okay
piggy where did you go
that was awesome did you see my job out
like man it's a pump of a pump I think
we need to go
oh this was the door that was locked I
would assume this way out it now where's
piggy heck are you doing there serious
is that okay baby I know you're scared I
know you're scared and I know you want
your final but oh yeah keep forgetting
is nice
barrels everywhere oh that's not good
for anyone
oh look at that it was perfectly
stunning ye
I'm piggy I can stand perfectly if I
want to and lay down if I want you there
we go that's my boy I miss my boy
I'm freakin misfire I don't even know
how you can [ __ ] up my boys pity
Jesus penis I think hiding higher I
don't even know anymore
saving go here
ah
as it's this
[Music]
Oh where's the demon coming bro okay
let's go here I don't even know anymore
I don't even penis okay
maybe something in here please be
something ah tender bucks good I wasted
two didn't MUX again too thin of X okay
that makes us that makes frankincense
actually doesn't really make something
else can you used to have her oh yeah
stop this is impossible to just climb
over and brown oh okay okay let's go
here
there - no there and I read that so
quick
No bye bye love bye bye happiness a
little it is spinning it where my chairs
I'll play I don't even hold it up baby
come down gonna beat it
cheer my would activate it OOP okay okay
share motor Jam oh man
alright they light that up that was
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay let's go here Oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] them [ __ ] my
[ __ ] bah okay go let's get the [ __ ] back
why why do I go back I'm not even
supposed to go there [ __ ] Barry I don't
even know anyone
[Music]
maybe I need this tone over maybe I got
away oh geez
stop Jesus change change
remember sham out I think we got all we
want it goes like this shadows over
there if we go here we already got all
our [ __ ] man we're done we're definitely
done I'm sorry guys I wasted two minutes
of your life is that happy are you happy
now I'm going I'm going I'm going I'm
not happy about this anymore not okay
you should know better okay
man oh man this custom started creeping
the hell out of me really it's been a
while since I've been so into playing
amnesia really there we go that's what I
was gonna say and I don't dress you now
where's the fun on seriously though no
[ __ ] I need him okay that's of course I
used that way okay what's going on
what's going on keep looping boy must be
somewhere around here
[Applause]
okay seriously this is like five times
good as white night I don't know what
people were like why night Chuck in
white pants you need to have a coach set
to up down
up five down 14 okay I'll try to
remember that
I'll try to remember and there's me
where's the machine oh [ __ ]
someone getting raped again
bro are you raping people in the machine
room really that's not even sexy mood I
guess I up five and down 14 right
that's not so difficult
it was that right up five down 14
up five down 14 yeah it's good
why isn't it working though
that's a question
why n-nah barking so rats
I don't
up five down 14 what the [ __ ] do you
want from me
there is an egg somewhere enough
there is another way to get 14 I guess
so if you go up with one of these
it's gotta be this one
up with that then we have up five and
then we have six eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen fifteen I'll get us too much
oh they all have to be somewhere
could be like this salsa
there's 5-man a lot i know you guys love
puzzles so much so interesting six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen yeah this should work huh
you're supposed to go down by damn right
that's what I say to my penis
damn boy damn boy okay I'm just kidding
okay okay I don't even know what I did
but you need to undress yourself did I
really do that
holy [ __ ] that was awesome okay I think
I think we will write my notes cuz I
don't even know this power is needed oh
yeah the lever I forgot are from you how
could you forget about Alaska
how could you forget you always forget
about Shamu - I'm super disappointed I
told him many times share mode and
you're like I'm gonna be scared and [ __ ]
Oh burn Shamu I told you share mode
activated OOP
don't leave me like this don't lay up
there close the door oh okay
pull the lever pull it over you don't
let you have a lot of time do you have a
lot of time a lot of time help me mr.
Sherr help me I don't even know anymore
huh it's wagging Betty rod I'm chaining
armature
nobody maybe a favorite of feu it won't
budge lime oh okay okay maybe it's in
here
maybe it's an air baby okay okay wait it
won't open anymore
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] for the fun part
I don't even know where to go I didn't
even oh come on I don't i bid the
machine he totally did that machine
maybe I'm supposed to go back in there
nothing good for anyone bro is like
raping oh he's talking through them I
know
[ __ ] net oh oh oh oh oh oh man okay
I'm a sheriff I'm a sheriff I'm a share
I'm a share I'm a freakin share camo I
thought he didn't see one like Shambo
white good night then okay we need to go
back in here nice side gagging damn why
didn't I just go in here I'm so stupid
wrong back yeah run Bank that's a good
feeling alright new adventures
coz then it's customized oh well done
I'm surprised heard stories about this
outside of the castle
well what kind of stones
actually they're more like rumors and
stores tomorr like IRA Wallace said that
Norma has entered this place for many
years all right I also say that if you
do you should be afraid I'm not afraid
and why is that be afraid are they
talking about
they drunk okay I'm scared I heard that
a long time ago the castles old owners
used to perform their sacrificial
rituals and after that is a permanent
presence of evil as they become our
permanent presence of co2
aah hey let's stay together I'm sure
that the four of us can and will remove
any obstacles will need along our way to
the old castle this is not good friend
of one sings Asian been a while since we
had a sensation and there one of this
happened none of us said I was not a man
attention I learned Bower and Andrey I
couldn't eat flies why do you figure
twice [ __ ] okay okay okay Franken okay
I love duck it's a shape again man
what's going on what's going on Peggy
holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] you are okay go go go go go go go
go go yeah bottom lip lip lip better it
rip that punt
thank you but lips a Fitbit this legend
we'll see are you I got bring it all
back you up get up the [ __ ] is Stefano
at least have letting that nap man that
off man I'm out of oil okay now my life
but I have Latin Adam Adam huh
what do they make me go here if they
gonna [ __ ] kill me
where's the key Susan though where's the
[ __ ] key
I need to go the other way don't stuff
never get up hold your head high and
read it the faster we'll see what you
have got make it all back here
leaving at me gonna make me [ __ ] hate
the water pump don't you [ __ ] dare
get the [ __ ] out of here fat pariah ah
okay
where the [ __ ] did I come up there huh
man I don't even know anymore where is
he
come over here
ah he's stuck you [ __ ] [ __ ]
hahahaha
oh [ __ ] is not talk anymore and he's
pissed now
Wow how I can get up there oh cool
[Music]
oh very good
[ __ ] good see you I don't know some
future crime oh man I'm glad that's over
okay we're good
do I have the hammer oh [ __ ] I need my
hammer don't worry piggy you'll find
your hammer Thank You mr. chair
okay I'm getting sick of Francis bossing
around I can't understand peanuts all
right
[ __ ] France is bashing around Hey
okay sorry I'm not gonna do that with
you cuz I love shares
oh no no no time I go back into water
come on
oh come on I thought for sure that was
done okay let's jump here oh good not
really that was perfect good jump beauty
Friday okay let's just walk slow and
maybe he doesn't know how to see ballet
that but I day by day by night age come
from everywhere get up dump dump dump
dump dump dump dump to dump I freaking
love jumping I freaking laugh
[Music]
okay it's bad enough I don't even care
hey hey [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh man
I don't even know anymore okay I
recorded for quite a while today and I'm
getting tired and I'm getting this is
too much I'm gonna have a [ __ ] I
don't know permanent magnesia psychology
damage if I continue I hope you have a
good one I'll see you actually it's
gonna be wise unless I see you because
I'm going away to Italy but yeah
[Music]
huh are you [ __ ] gay to me told me
his [ __ ] job no way no [ __ ] way